[Musique]
djiar ministre ose encore dit le déçu
c'est ici
[Rires]
[Musique]
coup de blues il tout seul alors
je trouve ces cas
[Musique]
ouaip avoir un taux majoré monsieur moto
beau ricky drouin page peur de les
perdre
les cheveux blancs ça c'est naturel les
amis j'ai pas mitchell là c'est vraiment
en sort c'est juste totalement naturelle
on est à l'authentiqué fallu faire
couper les cheveux au bureau tous les
fans
et pas suffisamment de l'humira quel est
le métier les gens qui n'ont pas de
métier
kelly se regarder en permanence sur
internet de regarder ce qui l'est c'est
ce qu'il me tâte regarde mais bien sûr
mais regardez dictionnaire un jour à la
place de colmater à la dia ba ouai bah
moi aussi web aux filles
ouais ouais alors dit deviens voudrais
que ça dure lanta usées m'a poussé
tout jusqu'à ce jour
[Musique]
merci raymond mahboula nous dérange pas
enfin d'un artiste on a appris ça je te
remets dans la nature voir
[Musique]